hello welcome to 2014 guys hopefully all
is good we're living the life without
Dan for the first like well not first
time but for the first stream of the
year
welcome it's torture chamber time we're
gonna play the big adventure of a
watchos life you'll see what that game
isn't in just a second once we get
switched over to it here we go oh that's
great oh I put the death counter on just
so you guys kid could watch so X is
shoot are you serious alright so that
post obviously reflects my bullets
apparently so I have one death holy [ __ ]
Wow I'll make it please the black spikes
sometimes he can jump really well and
sometimes he just come on I wonder if
there's an oh [ __ ] is that a pedobear
dude why does he have a stump you all
know nope
oh we can hit him oh no he got me with
this strong leg look at the tiny little
hook alright we're gonna know we're
gonna shoot this pedobear up oh oh let's
just go let's just go oh you're [ __ ]
me it's a trap
can you even kill this guy
I figured you out
who is this good I see immortal oh I got
him yes suck on that pedo bear oh oh oh
[ __ ] he just walked off the ledge he
walked off the ledge you have to make
the jump from the box son of it
alright fine at least we killed the pedo
bear so you're saying I can make this
jump all right good maybe try under the
platform which platform the big platform
oh this is the one I was at the edge of
the floating platform and I still missed
the jump trigger the spikes then go
under the spikes alright
oh [ __ ] alright hold on we'll try that
we'll try that what's down here oh shoot
Scott
flashget huh little little pixelated
flash kick from mr. go home and be a
family man press F when the spikes come
down on you okay let's try that does
that make me invulnerable F that didn't
I don't know I don't know why why I
chose this game oh come on
yes Oh what is that can I kill it Oh
e Honda mother F and E Honda up in this
whoo-hoo you want to see this look
hundred hand slap hundred hand slap
you're not shooting me
yeah can I jump over it how about some F
you want some F there some steam there
an invisible box yeah that's the worst
Oh baby come on mr. flash kick yes yes
oh [ __ ] alright can I jump it o-genki
okay okay all is well miss me oh it
didn't come out that time a phantom
flashy come on
he's freaking Russian size 15 boot suck
on that
Zangief I was over here hmm I played
enough of these games where I don't feel
like I trust these platforms oh that's
not so bad oh that would try to trick me
went up what are those guys wonder
what's going on here you guys is that
like a what oh that's great that's real
good
oh that was Shady
Oh what if I did F under the little box
okay f F press s where's su oh what is
that oh you like that noise like right
when the spikes come down nice it's s is
to strike a pose and do nothing fancy
death post I don't know what to do then
if that doesn't do anything for me and
this doesn't do anything for me walk
under it walk past them great thanks
guys just hop on it just little tapper
ooh little skip oh yeah oh yeah thank
you thank you a little look at that guy
it's like a fat version of me says to go
down but I feel sketchy about it
I feeI but see I don't know if this
guy's my friend either do you think that
since he looks kind of like me that he's
my friend or you think he's gonna turn
on us or turn on me I always find out oh
yeah okay okay come on Big O you just
leave me let's just listen to the sign
here okay
also a trap so down is definitely not
the way so let's try this
oh yeah you're the lucky player please
click here [ __ ] why do you want why
would I listen my life is end why do I
even listen to the game alright let's
see if we can just walk by cuz I don't
know I don't feel like let's just get my
cursor away from that
let's just not alright alright oh
there's a ladder okay
I feel like this square is here for a
reason
oh that's sick the letter breaks apart
the ladder breaks apart can I even climb
this ladder
so you think jump from the ladder to the
wall and then back to the ladder alright
oh that's cool what just what just
happened
am i swimming am I am I just clipping
through this game no I'm I'm actually
stuck I'm stuck I can't go left and I
can't go right I guess I could click on
the sign alright so they're saying use
the column press n you guys are telling
me all that pose buttons I don't care
about the pose buttons I make it up oh
it's there's no lines those are lies all
right so I made the jump from here
who'll climb it climb like a boss okay I
got it I got it I got it I got it I got
it I'm at the save all right let's find
out we got to find out for science right
for science Oh
seek oh [ __ ] what is that let the boss
oh [ __ ] that what is this meteors oh I'm
dead is this the first boss nothing
looks safe none of it looks safe except
no and then he comes down so I can't
hide under oh can I hide in the back
right corner and just shoot him oh I'm
gonna do that what do you think about
that switch hey hey hey come down here
what what can I hit box is that we can
clearly see that I fit in that corner oh
ok I get I get it except you can't okay
so you can shoot the small ones but not
the big ones and if I shoot him the big
ones come out you try to get to the top
box like right away at the top of his
afro Oh Shh oh yeah oh yeah hack it yeah
oh I'm so dead leave me alone
alright okay okay
strategy is sound just strategy is sound
okay
I'm scared hooli I'm scared I'm scared
oh go over my head yeah yeah so check
oppose to stick why did I strike a pose
there oh no you stupid spike oh no sweat
too much swag for you too much swag for
you afro oh oh no okay
all right guys thank you for tuning in
we're gonna still do this every Friday
torture chamber hashtag GS torture you
can tweet me at ey ta Y follow at
GameSpot for your updates for whenever
we stream we're gonna scream more this
year again we're going to revamp but
definitely if you guys have game
suggestions either like this or
different that you think our torture
chamber esque go ahead and tweet at me
at UI ta Y with the hashtag GS torture
recommend your game maybe I'll try it
we'll see I haven't picked the game for
next week yet but hopefully you liked
the big adventure of mr. iwata's life I
think I think I got that right something
close to that but the links there if you
want to try it yourself you can tell me
hey Eric I beat it and you suck but
we'll see but thanks for watching
f2b kill the mics bye